Let's go next to Ausman from
Karachi. Losman, you're on.
Losman.
Boozman from Karachi, I heard
background noise. What's going on?
No. Yes.
Go, go, good. You are killing me. I can hear you.
Or die. Michael IHC or you let go like a few
months ago. Don't go. Live from Pakistan.
I do remember.
As is is my voice.
I did I knew it was lastone, you
know, your voice is sounding OK. Yeah.
Oh, OK, OK, cool.
OK. I wanted to ask you a question, basically.
I'm still on, right? You're still on. OK, OK.
I basically wanted to ask you a question about
Latin American politics.
So you've you've got this idea is that many
toity and leftist leaders like, you know, Fidel
Castro, people will show. Is all those guys
partly or do you think that in your opinion.
Were there any are they like
us or center left who do.
Oh, fair. They left like it is
like for example, Lutalo was emoji guy. Oh, boy.
Like, do you think. Do you mean by anybody or like
me. Like there was like this woman in
Paraguay or Shaley. I don't remember like. But
you do think they were like any better leaders.
Absolutely. Absolutely. So while there are
certainly overlaps between someone like
Hugo Chavez and Cosimo Hiccough in Uruguay,
there is it is really night and day in total.
And Cosimo hiccough, someone that I would
would would be is much closer to my politics.
And it doesn't mean I would agree with him on
everything. But no question about it. And, you
know, when people say, David, you're you're
just some you're really a right winger, you
know, when he whatever. No, I'm I'm an anti
authoritarian. And while Mossimo, he might have
some particular views that I don't agree with.
He was not an authoritarian. The way Hugo
Chavez was. And so for sure. For sure. I
consider them different categories altogether.
Oh, OK. Can I ask you another question? Sure.
OK. OK. Good one. One second, I forgot, I forgot.
Well. Well, listen, I've got a lot of people
waiting, so call back again. Wee
wee. If you forgot the question,
let's let's move on, because there are lots
of people who do who do want to chat today